it's our final countdown for today's  show all right let's bring in our  virtual friends over there they are high  virtual friends  all right up on the screen is victoria  from middletown connecticut  hi victoria hi drew i'm so excited to be  here and meet you  um i just loved your conversation about  dating apps because i actually met my  boyfriend  on tinder and we just celebrated our six  year anniversary this month  i know um but i'm curious to know  what is your dream date uh  what what is my dream date oh my god  okay uh i have  okay um uh  laughing laughing a lot someone who's  kind  someone who's kind and funny i wouldn't  mind some smarts in there too  but kind and funny that's those are the  two main ingredients for me for a date  or a relationship  and thank you for asking okay well good  for you i love the hope thank you  all right we have time for one no we ran  out of time oh god  and to everyone who may be watching us i  hope that your day is full of sunshine  you